What I eat
as a mom who's focused on optimal fertility and hormone health
and as someone who avoids seed oils,
artificial sugars,
dyes, and preservatives at all costs.
Pasture raised raw yolks and eggs for cholesterol and choline,
which are vital for baby's brain development.
Next, the most nutrient dense food on earth liver,
which is rich in folate and vitamin A
and necessary for the birth of a healthy,
well developed baby.
I like to take birthright on a daily basis
because it's the only real food supplement that contains raw,
freeze dried liver
from regeneratively farmed cows that graze on lush pasture
free of hormones,
pesticides, Gmos, and glyphosate.
In addition, my meals focus around pasture raised meats
which are rich in amino acids,
essential fat soluble vitamins,
iron, and protein.
I use leftover bones to make gelatinous
rich bone broths which are especially nourishing,
and I use broths to cook sprouted grains and to make soups with
when making bread.
I always source organically grown grains and stone,
trying them immediately before souring and fermenting
to pre digest the grain
and make vitamins more bioavailable to my body.
I eat sauerkraut often for its probiotics
which contribute to a healthy gut microbiome.
And I prioritize pasture fats which are rich in fat soluble vitamins A,
D, E, and K2.
And lastly, raw dairy from grass grazed cows,
especially when cultured,
is a superfood and I incorporate it into my daily diet.